-My next guest
executive-produces and stars in
the big, new reboot of "iCarly"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm mad about "iCarly."
You can see new episodes every
Thursday on Paramount+.
Please welcome Miranda Cosgrove!
[ Cheers and applause ]
- ♪ Miranda Cosgrove,
she's flyin' high ♪
♪ America's sweetheart ♪
♪ And Carly with an "I" ♪
♪ I got more questions ♪
♪ And get you to say no ♪
-Miranda Cosgrove.
Look at that, come on.
Look.
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
We love you.
-Thank you.
-Miranda, welcome to the show.
-Thank you so much
for having me.
I'm so excited to be here.
-We love you.
Actually, we've worked together.
-Yes.
-I was so happy to be on
an episode of "iCarly."
But I want to -- I want to talk
to you all about that.
But, first, I don't know
if you've noticed this,
but you've kind of become
the queen of memes.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
It's true. My legacy.
-Your legacy.
-The queen of memes.
-Yeah, since you were -- How old
were you when you first started?
-Meming?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, exactly.
You didn't even know
you were meming at the time.
-I think the first meme
that became popular of me,
I was 8 or 9.
-Yeah, 8 years old.
And I have a couple of them
because I want to show everyone
in case you need a good meme.
-Oh, boy.
-Here's one that says,
"When they finally play
Sum 41 'Fatlip'
at the house party."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I was obsessed with doing this,
and I really paid for it.
Like, I just couldn't stop
doing that.
-It's so cute.
Are you kidding me?
Come on, like, "Nice try."
[ Laughter ]
I like this one, too.
This is interesting.
[ Laughter ]
"Seeing your friend
tweet someone they 'hate.'"
"Interesting."
[ Laughter ]
You made the "interesting" face.
And then what I thought
was funny is
that the new "iCarly,"
the reboot,
you redid the "interesting" face
as a joke,
and that became a meme.
[ Light laughter ]
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-It took on a life of its own.
[ Laughter ]
-New interesting.
Yeah, yeah.
It's got a life of its own.
-[ Laughs ]
-You reunited
with the cast of "iCarly."
Did you know you were
going to do the reboot,
or were you just supposed
to just show up
for, like, one episode reunion,
or how did you...
-We knew we were gonna do
the revival,
and we were super excited,
but we got a call
to all go to this event
and we were supposed to
announce it together that we
were gonna be doing a revival.
So, my friend, Jerry Trainor,
who plays my brother
on "iCarly" --
-I love Jerry.
-He's the best.
So, he called me up
and he was like, "You know,
with COVID, we've been inside.
We could use some sun."
He was like, "I know you've
gotten a spray tan before.
Do you think
you could hook me up,
and the two of us could get
a spray tan together?"
So, I was like, "Okay."
Like, it's so out of character
for Jerry.
I didn't expect it at all.
-Yeah, that's --
-So I said, "Sure, yeah."
So we went,
we got the spray tan together,
and then the next morning
was the event,
and I didn't hear from him.
I kept texting him,
"How's it going?"
Like, "Do you like
how it turned out?"
I wasn't hearing from him.
So, then,
the way spray tans work,
if you -- I don't know
if you've ever had one,
but if you get one,
it keeps developing
until you wash it off.
So, he fell asleep, and
he never washed it off.
And the next morning,
I brought --
This is a picture for you.
This is what happened.
[ Laughter ]
[ Sad trombone plays ]
It's pretty bad.
-Dude, look at that.
Oh, my gosh.
It looks like he's burnt.
-I love this picture.
I had it as my wallpaper
on my phone for a long time.
Anytime I'm sad,
I look at this picture
and it makes me feel so good.
-He looks like -- He looks like
the color of the blimp.
-He's Nickelodeon orange.
Yeah, that's what he went with.
Was he -- Was he mad?
-So, he was very upset,
and he blamed me.
And then, later, we were filming
an episode for the show,
and in the episode,
I'm supposed to make
this kind of crazy,
hideous face.
And it's turn into
this giant Andy Warhol-type
piece of art in the episode.
So he asked if he
could take it home
when we finished the episode
and he put it up in his house
to get me back.
-Here's the piece of art.
-That's the piece of art.
I'm supposed to be
eating a meatball.
[ Laughter ]
-That's that.
And then here's Jerry with you.
-And showing it to me
is his revenge.
-In his living room.
[ Laughter ]
I love it.
Please send -- send my regards
to the whole cast.
People are loving this reboot,
by the way.
-Thank you.
-100% fresh on Rotten Tomatoes.
100%. It's awesome.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
It already got renewed
for season two.
Where does it pick up, this?
-It's pretty much
eight years
after the old one ended.
It's just
all the same characters
and what they're
going through now.
Now that we're older, and
it's a much more mature take.
We're doing stuff in this one
we couldn't do in the old.
-Yeah, and the audience
for this, is it --
they're not kids now.
-No, it's really for
the original audience
that's grown-up.
-Yeah, that's brilliant,
and it works.
You figured it out.
That's awesome.
It's worth -- I want to show
a clip right now.
Here is Miranda Cosgrove
in "iCarly."
Take a look.
-Freddie, just hand me
that, uh, twisty thingy.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, this is no big deal.
-Alright.
-Aah!
Ow!
-Hey!
I got ya. Come on!
-Aah!
Son of a [Horn honks]
-You know what? That's okay.
I've almost got it.
Freddie, go check
the spark plugs.
-Alright.
-Millicent, start 'em up!
[ Engine sputtering ]
-Oh!
[ Horn honks ]
-Millicent, stop that!
-Then you two stop cussing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ah. We're down, buddy.
Miranda Cosgrove.
Check out new episodes
of "iCarly"
every Thursday on Paramount+.